[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباريون خاص ومتنوع وبايقاع سريعا ومختلف
جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق وبين
العاشر والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم وسوره
الكامله البدايه من العناوين
غليانه
تقابله صوره هادئه بنظر السلطات
وسائل العلاج الا بطرد الرجال روحاني
روسيا تتاهب من باحتها الغربيه لام المدني
كياف الهجوم الشامل خطر كبير
وفي ملفات الساعه الستون طالبان بين
طالبان باكستان ونساء باكيات محتجات وعالم
غاضب الحركه لا تسمع لا ترى لكنها تبرر
ابل محاصره بميزات اندرويد الاسلاك واحده
منها تبدو شائكه وقوانين اوروبا تريد
حمايه البيئه
[موسيقى]
الوضع وطبعا وهدى رؤيه السلطات الايرانيه
لا تختلف ورويتها لا تختلف مهما اختلف حجم
الاحتجاجات في الشارع النظام يخطط لدعوه
فنانين وباحثين دوريين لمهرجانات افلام
ومسرح لكن في الباحه الخلفيه يعتقل
حنين الذين يعارضون قمع المتظاهرين
والامثله كثيره واخرها ترانا علي دوستي
تهم معدومه وان كان النظام قادرا على
اختلاقها نددت الممثله الشهيره باعدام
المتظاهرين نعلم الان عن اعتقال علي دوستي
لشهرتها وهي التي شاركت بافلام عالميه
وتضامن معها كبار الفنانين العالميين لكن
خلف الابواب الموصده هناك اخرون بعضهم
مجهول المصير واخرون معرضون لخطر الاعدام
ثمانيه وخمسون شخصا ابي حسب منظمتها رانا
الحقوقيه الواقع اذا ليس طبيعيا ولا هادئا
يسرقوا بكلمات المعاكسه لكلمات السلطات
وفقه كل التصورات وهكذا ترى الدول الغربيه
قمع النظام المتهم بنظره او في روايهته
على الدوام بتاجيج الشارع الايراني علينا
القيام ابي يجعل المواطنين يعتقدون ان
الاحتجاجات من عمل الاجانب تسريبات
السابقه لخمينائي بدا المسؤولون في
تنفيذها والقي القبض على اسرائيليين
وصفتهم ايران بالجواسيس كانوا يخططون
لتنفيذ اعمال ارهابيه خلال التظاهرات
خامنئي اذا يعتقد وان ابداء مرونه في ما
يتعلق بركائز الايديولوجيا الايرانيات
سيؤدي الى انهيارها ولذلك لا حل سوها
مضاعفه القمع من تنفيذ تهديد قطع الانترنت
الى استخدام التكنولوجيا في اختراق
المحادثات الخاصه
بالناشطين ووصولا للاعتداء الجنسيه على
السجنات ومعرفه السبب هنا لا يبطل العجب
بل يزيد الدهون ارتدوا الحجاب
وبعض عمليات اغتصابيه المتظاهرات يتم
تصويرها لاجبارهن على التزام الصمت مضاعفه
القمع وكتم صوت الشارع استدعى مضاعفه
العقوبات الغربيه واستدعمها مر سلبيه
كثيره الاقتصاد ان يتهاون كل يوم عن سابقه
ادنى مستوى التومان امام الدولار
40,000 وحتى ليله يلدا التي تحتفل بها
الاسر الايرانيه كل سنه وصادفت هذا العام
الحادي والعشرين من ديسمبر وتقيمها بموائد
من الطعام تحولت من سعيده الى تعيسه فقدت
الليله بريقها مراكز التسوق في ايران شبه
فارغه القفزه الجنونيه في اسعار السلع
الاساسيه
لا يستطيعون تحمل هذه الاسعار لان ال 60%
منهم ماتوا تحت خط الفقر
كل هذه الاوضاع السيئه يمكن ان تتضاعف مع
عدم تخلي الغرب عن العقوبات الجديده
والعقوبات القائمه المتعلقه بالاتفاق
النووي الميت موطن
انتفاضه الايرانيين ولا نتحدث هنا عن كلمه
بيضا بل تلك التي يصرخ بها اهالي
المحتاجين في المقابر
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صدام
الايرانيين وان اختلف نمطها طابعها واحد
ولا يتغير وان حاول النظام طمسها او ان
يمحي تفاصيلها ومعالمها على عتبه المئه
يوم تبقى ميزه الاصرار على اسقاط النظام
الموت لخامينا مطلب وانا مرتفع السقف لا
تهداته يستوجب على الاقل الاصلاحات غير
انا هذه الكلمه صعبه في القاموس الايراني
خلينا يعرف ان الثوره انتصرت في اللحظه
التي شعرك قادتها بانشاء يفكر بتقديم
اصلاحات وهل يخاطر المرشد ومؤسسات النظامه
ورجاله المتشددون بالخضوع للشارع وتغيير
سلوكهام
الاجابه بلا انتظار او مراجعه
لسلوك القمع والقتل الاعتقال والاعدامات
في ثلاثه اشهر ومن سطح التصريحات
الدبلوماسيه حسين امير عبد اللهن راس
الخارجيه الايرانيه نظام ايران الديمقراطي
وكغيره من الانظمه الديمقراطيه معرضا
للصعود والهبوط والفتيات الايرانيات
الشابات مرتزقه دسهن الاعداء لخلع اغطيه
رؤوسهم في شوارع البلاد والكلام هنا لاحمد
عالم الهدى ممثل الخامنائي في مدينه مشهد
بعيده عن الواقع وربما هي اقرب الى
السخريه بالنسبه للراي العام الذي باست
تشكله طاقه الرفض والمجابهه التحدي
والاصرار ولكن للمفارقه في جوهر هذه
التصريحات الامر جدي
ومصيريا بالنسبه لنظام ترتبط باستمراريهته
بشكل مباشر بالايديولوجيا
تواجه اليوم اختبار صعبا يتمثل في رفض رمز
الثوره وازاحه الرمز سيؤدي الى تداعي
الايديولوجيا تماما كما يتداعل بناء عند
ازاحه حجر الزاويه
الاعداء هم السبب ومن جميع انحاء العالم
بحسب حسين سلامي قائد الحرس الثوري من
قبله ومن بعده خامنئي رئيسي عبد الله وزير
الداخليه احمد وحيد وغيرهم باختصار
الروايه المعلمه في اطار تخوين المحتجين
والتدخل الخارجي لكن هناك من خرج عن اطار
المالوف الى الماء
توفوا منه افتح كده
ايران من فعل الاعداء فماذا فعلناه حتى
يؤثر كلام الاعداء على الناس
تحت الرماد ويجب ان يعيد النظر في اداره
البلاد
المرشد النصف الاخر سنعود اليه لكن الاكيد
ان هناك من مبدا بالقوه للتعبير عن وجوب
الاصلاحات
اداريه كشفار حتى
النجاه ممكن
[موسيقى]
قالبه في اول المنشقين وهو القائد السابق
في الحرس الثوري هي حرب داخليه
رئيس البرلمان فشيلات في تحسين الاوضاع
المعيشيه الايرانيين في ضلي تراجع القدره
الشرائيه وانهيار العملاء
الى عبد الناصر هم في رئيس البنك المركزي
في حكومه روحانيه
بعد تنصلها من مسؤوليه الفشل الاقتصاديه
وتحميلها للحكومه السابقه وخداع الشعب
اتهام مباشره
بالارقام الرسميه
المنطقه كي لا نقول الكذبه التضخم الذي
تتلقف الحكومه المتعاقبتان مسؤوليه في
شعره يبلغ اليوم
84% في حين كان يبلغ 34 في المئه عام
2020,000 في عهد روحاني وعندما تولى رئيس
مصر منصبه رئيسيه ايران كانت الدولار
الامريكي يساوي 230,000 ريال في اسواق
الطيران والان قيمه كل دولار امريكي تزيده
عن
380,000 ريال ومع ذلك يبقى نصف الحقيقه
الاخر الذي التي تحدثنا عنها غائبا من
يهند السياسات البلاد ومن يقوى على عكس
واقع الحياه الايرانيين على جميع الاصابات
لا احد يحكم هنا سوى المرشد واحنا نتحدث
عن الاقتصاد والكعكه المقسمه بين خامنئه
والحرس الثوري وبدايه تقسيمها كانت في عام
سته بمرسوم خامنئي لخصخصه 80% من القطع
العامه فتحت بموجبه بوابه الحرس الثوري من
العسكر والسياسه الى الاقتصاد بتصفيه
شركات الدوله انضم اقل من 14% منها فقط
للقطاع الخاص وما تبقى من اصول
86% قيمتها 70 مليار دولار ذهبت الى
القطاع شبه الحكومي الذي استحدث حينها
للحرس الثوري ومؤسساته ومؤسسات المرشد ومن
بينها تلك التي تستتر تحت مظله الاعمال
الخيريه بحجم 200 مليار دولار هذا بتوثيق
امريكيه رسميه
تحت عيني و ضوء المرشد الاخضر تاسست خاتم
الانبياء الشركات التي تتجاوز قيمتها
المئه مليار دولار غطاء مقاولات هندسيه
يضم
815 شركه في البلاد والخارجها مهمتها كانت
تدمير القطاع الخاص بمد الحرس يده الى
قطاعات اخرى كالتصالات طبعا لاغراض امنيه
وتلبيها حصه 51% من شركه الاتصالات
الايرانيه استحفظ عليها الحرس الثوري في
2009 مقابل سبعه مليارات و800 مليون دولار
وهناك ايضا البتروكيماويات الصناعات
الثقيله قطاعات السيارات الصحه والسرعه في
حلولي 2009 ايضا كانت المصارف الخاصه تملك
فقط 34% من الودائع طويله الامد في البلاد
وخمسه وعشرين في المئه فقط من الوداع
قصيره الامل
يا ذهبت الى 12 مصرفا ومؤسسا ماليه مرتبطه
في الحرس الثوري ومن خلالها يتحكم باسعار
الفائده ويشغل حسابات المصرفيه وهميه بلغ
عددها في 2015 بحسب البنك المركزي
الايراني
بريئاستهمته 38 مليون حساب استخدمت في
صفقات مشهوره
مبالغ طائله في مختلف القطاعات حددت من
حصول رجال الاعمال على قرودا لتطوير
اعمالهم مقابل الرفاهيه المطلقه لشركات
الحرس وقياداتهم المتكئين على وساده من
ريش عام النفط والغاز مهمه الاستحباب
الموكله لمقر خاتم الانبياء بحصص ثابته
المقايضه احيانا
[موسيقى]
اذا نفوذ انا بحجم دوله وصلاحيات تمتد على
طولها وعرضها يجعلني عوده ايران للاتفاق
النووي بالغه التعقيد في امبراطوريه
ضخمتها العقوبات لن يقبل اصحابها عوده
التعاملات القانونيه حتى انه لا يخفي
مصلحته في فرض المزيد من القيود ويحضرني
الان تصريح ابرز قاده الحرس محمد رضا نقدي
العام الماضي رحب بالمزيد من العقوبات على
انها تشجع على الاكتفاء الذاتي صحيح الحرس
البائع الوحيد لنفط ايران في السوق
السوداء هناك 123 ناقله نفط تهرب النفط
الى الصين
الايميل كما ان الحرس الثوريه يبقى
مستفيدا من حاله العداء الايرانيه مع
واشنطن لجهه اجنداته سعي قال من الشويه في
المنطقه وبالطبع لا يريد فتح ابواب
الاستمارات برفع العقوبات عن بلدنا اي
يحاربوا فيها الحرس الثوري مشاريع القطاع
الخاص المحليه رغم ذلك تطرح ايران العوده
المفاجئه للاطفاء اذا عدتم عدنا هكذا
خاطبه عبد اللهيان قوه الاتفاق وبشروط
اسهل من ذي قبل لو قبل المسؤولون الغربيون
فسينقدون النظام الايراني اقتصاديا
ويخرجونه من ازمته الداخليه لكن الرد
الغربي جاء بترتيب الاولويات الاحتجاجات
حقوق الانسان وقت بيع مسيرات الايرانيه
لروسيا والرد الامريكي
ميت
غمر
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا تيمور
الياسي عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
في جنيف اهلا بك اذا هذه الاصوات التي من
قلب النظام تتحدث عن وجوب الاصلاحات بعد
ثلاثه اشهر من التظاهرات بعد انهيار
الاقتصاد بشكل واضح وبشكل كارثي بعد
اعدامات يتحدث الان مسؤولون من داخل
النظام وحتى لو كانوا من الحكومه السابقه
بوجوب الاصلاحات هل هذا مؤشر جيد بما
يتعلق بممارسه العنف على المحتاجين
وممارسه الاعدامات هل هذا قد يشكل ضغطا
على النظام حاليا
حبيبي
الايراني
لا يصدق
بهذا الحديث عن الاصلاحات في النظام
فعلى مدى 25 سنه شاهدنا محاولات النظام
خاتمي وروحاني كل من هؤلاء في السلطه
الايراني
انت اسمك يوسف
لا يقنع المتظاهرين ولا الشباب همم
والمتظاهرين سيواصلون حتى ينهوا النظام
كامله نعم هناك ايضا الضغوط اخرى ومخاوف
من قبل حكومه الرئيسي ايضا بعد مصادر تحدث
الساعه 60 قالت ان هناك عمليات تصريح
لخمسه الاف موظف هم يتبعونه لحكومه
روحانيه اذا وضعنا وضع الداخلي او
الانشقاق لنقول الانشقاق بين المسؤولين في
همم ايران جانبا ونظرنا الى الموقف الدولي
الان الغربي يقول ان الاولويات هي وقف
الاحتجاجات العنف ووقف بيع المسيرات
لروسيا هل هذا موقف كافن لدافع عن النظام
لتغيير سياسته تجاه هذه الاحتجاجات
ولد ميشيل الرجيم
وكانها عمليه تجميليه
ولا يصدقها الاقليات والشباب من
المتظاهرين في ايران
[موسيقى]
هل هذا كافر
لوقف هذه الانتهاكات بحقوق الانسان
والله
ما نطلبهم من المجتمع الدولي
هو
عقوباتنا على
الحرس الثوري
بمجمله
كامؤسسه وليس كافراد
اما بالنسبه
لبيع المسيارات لروسيا هو سبب مشكله كبيره
لكن هو لا يؤثر على الشعب
الاوكرانيه هو جزء بسيط من المشكله وان
نظرنا الى دول الجوار الايراني بالعراق
وسوريا ولبنان واليمن مره التورث الايراني
والتخريب الذي اوصلته سياسات الايرانيه ما
نحن بحاجه اليه هو موقف قوي من دول الغرب
حاضر
لوقف منابع التمويل التي يتصل الى ايران
من اجل وقف تمويل
النشاطات الايرانيه داخل ايران وخارجها ما
نريد ان نراه هو ان يتوقف الاوروبيين عن
بيع السلاح للنظام الايراني ووقف شراء
النفط من ايران
الوقت
منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه في جنوب
[موسيقى]
انتظرها الاوكرانيون طويلا ووصلت اخيرا
لكن تم التحكم عليها هل عددها لانها قديمه
في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
منذ بدايه الحرب
السعيد
لا تحدث نفس السعاده في نفوس الاوكرانيين
سيصلون
منظومه واحده فقط
زاد بظهورها اطل واصحب مرتين في اقل من 48
ساعه ليست عادت بوتن على الاقل منذ بدايه
الحرب لديه الكثير ليقوله عدا السخريه من
منظومه فاتريه والكثير من الحماس على ما
يبدو بخطه الحرب الجديده لكن قبل الحديث
عن مرحله الحرب المقبله لنقعد قليلا الى
صباح الرابع والعشرين من فبراير انفجارات
عنيفه تهزوا اكياف وادسا
شامل على اربعه محاور
لننظر الى الخريطه مشاهدينا
خيرسون ودوم بس الجزء الاهم من القوات
هاجم انطلاقا من اراضي بيلاروسيا بهدف
تطبيق كياب خطه روسيه كانت مكشوفه قبل
تنفيذها مطار جاستميل مفتاح السر وبالفعل
الذي حصل القوات الروسيه في الاستيلاء
عليه لكن تدميرك يا ابن الجسور افشل الخطه
موسكو حاولت لاسابيع قبل ان تنسحب من
محورين وسومي الخطوه التاليه كانت تركيز
على تومدم باس لكن افقد ذلك روسيا
المبادره في بقيه المناطق وبصول قوات
اوكرانيه مدربه في دول النيته ومجهزه
باسلحه متطوره انسحبت روسيا من اقليم
خاركب ثم من لمان فخرسون ثلاث انكسات لم
يقبلها
الروسته في الاكتفاء بالدفاع طيله الشتاء
كانت حيله كان بنظر الاوكرانيين وراء هذه
الحواجز الاسمنتيه يستعد الجيش الروسي
اللي يشن هجوم الشام من خلال الاسابيع
الستات المقبله الاستخبارات السوريه اكدت
اذا تحضيرات حكومه
بي ام
جوني
اما المكان
في ظل تاكيداتي موسكو على تكبير اوكرانيا
خسائر كبيره في جبهه باخمود التقارير
تتحدث عن تغيير روسيا لتكتيكاتها هناك
اولا عبر زياده تعزيزات العسكريه من معدات
الثقيله ومدرعات
وزياده عدد القوات الروسيه هناك وبالاخص
قوات فاكنر الخاصه ثانيا العامليات
المستمره للمجموعات الصغيره من المشاهد في
جبهه واسعه وبدعم من المركبات المدرعه
لكنما اقلق اوكرانيا هو وجود القوات
الروسيه في بيلاروسيا واجراءها لتدريبات
تكتيكيه مكثفه بعد وصولها الى هناك لتشكيل
مجموعات اقليميه مشتركه وهو ما يعني
امكانيه وجود مخطط للهجوم على كيف من جبهه
مسك التي زارها بوتر مؤخرا لكن هذه
التقارير نفاها الكريملين ماذا عن كيف
هناك
العسكريه اقصى درجات الحذر وتجهز نفسها
لكافه السيناريوهان
فاصلا على الحدود الاوكرانيه البيلاروسيا
وابعته باسلاك شائكه ثم خنادق وقامت بزرع
الالغام على كامل الحدود كما عززتني
القوات امن الحدود وفصائل الجيش
الاوكرانيه المختلفه كما ارسلت اللواء
الثامنه والخمسين الى مثلث الحدود
الاوكرانيه الروسيه الروسيه وذلك على
الرغم من ان القياده العسكريه ترى ان
الروس يركزون جهودهم في دون وهو ما سيعيق
فتحهم لجبهه جديده في الوقت
كما ذكر مراسلنا لا تاكيد رسمي حول هجوم
الشامل تتفق واشنطن لا ادله ولا مؤشرات
وبوتن لن يغامر بشعبيتهم مجددا قبل
الاستعداد الجيد اهميه العاصمه لا تسمح
بالمجازفه مره اخرى
قبل العوده لمحوري كليب الجيش الروسي
يحتاج المزيد من الوقت لتجميع قوته وتعويض
خساره
في سنوات كامله لهندسه هجومها الاول على
ثياب ولا المفارقه سبقتهم منورات مع عبد
الله روسيا وباء الهجوم بالفشل والرغم ان
وقتها لم تكن اوكرانيا بقوه واستعداد ما
هي عليه اليوم هنا ياتي خيار التواجد
العسكري الروسي في بيلاروسيا والهدف صاحب
جزء من القوات الاوكرانيه بعيدا عن خط
المواجهه 900 كيلو متر من الحدود مع
الجاره الشماليه بناء التحصينات وحراسه
الحدود يستنزف قدرات كيا
خيار اخر روسيا نقلت صواريخ كنغال الى
بيلاروسيا مدى الصواريخ الروسيه يصل الى
كيا فلاحه هنا لمطارات بيلاروسيا وتبدو
رساله اكثر منها خيار الى روسيا مشاركه في
الحرب الحليب المتبقي لروسيا تفصله عن
الحدود 300 كم فقط
وذخيره للمدفعيه دعم لافت مقارنه بجيشها
المتواضع 50 الف جنديه مع امكانيه تعبئه
500 الف جندي اذا اضفنا ذلك للاقتراح
الروسي الاخير بزياده حجم الجيش بثلاثين
في المئه نتحدث عن مليون و500,000 جندي
هذا السيناريو بالطبع يخيب ثياب
غير ان تجهيز هذه القوات تحدي اخر المشكله
حلت ولو الجزئيا وهذه نظره اقرب على
اولويات الصناعه الروسيه هي كفيله بكشف
اهداف المرحله المقبله
انتاجي الدبابات تحديدا سلاح الهجنيا
الرئيسي في العقيده الروسيات
2500 دبابه من طراز ياتي 90 ام حديثه باتت
ابي حوزه الجنود وثلاثه الاف دبابه اخرى
تحديثها
[موسيقى]
كيف امه المدن الروسيه كلام نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن
الروسينا بشان الهجوم الشامل على العاصمه
لكن الواقع على الارض مؤشراته تقول وعكس
ذلك
انطلاقا من بيلاروسيا والسبب هو فشلها في
السيطره
وهنا عدت اوكرانيا
دفاعيه على طول الحدود جدران اسمنتيه
وحقول الغابه العبور لخط الدفاع الاول لا
يعد تحدي كبير لكن هذه المره روسيا تعول
على دباباتها المحدثه في 90 وفي 14
بميزاتها المهمه درعا تفاعلي ينفجر بمجرد
اقتراب الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات ويعني
ذلك ان المدرعات الروسيه لن تكون فريسه
السنجر او
طريق واحد يقود اليك وهنا التجربه في صالح
الاوكرانيين والبدايه من تشرنوبل ثم بوتشا
واربيني واوكرانيا حولت هذه المدن الى
تحصنه ادفاعيه سيناريو باخموت يبدو انه
سيتكرر الهجوم الشامل ممكن لكن باهداف اقل
رمزيات خيار اخر بيدي بوتن مدينته بوابه
اوكرانيا وهي الاخرى غير بعيده 300 كم
تفصل برس برستل بلاروسيا عن الفيف
والسيطره عليها يعني الكثير قطعوا
الامدادات الغربيه وبدونها
لن يصمد طويلا لكن هذا الخيار يحمل عده
مخاطر والاول ان البيئه قريبه جدا من
الحدود الفولنديه سقوط صاروخ او قذيفه
واحده قد هيجر روسيا لحربا مع النيته
والثاني
قوافل الجيش الروسي لم تحظى بدعم الطيران
انظمه باتريوت التي اعلن بايدا تسليمها
لزنس في خلال زيارته لواشنطن تحرس الحدود
وعدا عن تسليم قطعه واحده منها فقط كما
ذكرنا بوتا لا هو راي اخر
مشاجره يعني
[موسيقى]
عندما سحبت الولايات المتحده قواتها من
افغانستان قبل اكثر من عام كانت تعهد
طالبان
للجماعات الارهابيه ليس تنظيم القاعده فقط
وانما توامها الايديولوجي طالبان باكستان
التي تصنفها واشنطن ارهابيه منذ 2010
بوعوده نظيرتها الافغانيه
الحركه الباكستانيه هشه مع اسلام اباد قبل
الهدنه وبعدها اظهرت الارقام
والاجابه تاتي من الحدود فقط في الاشهر
الثلاثه الاخيره اكثر مني 250 هجوما انطلق
من افغانستان تبنته طالبان باكستان اي ضعف
عدد العمليات التي نفذتها عام 2020 واكثر
بثلاث مرات من تلك التي نفذتها عام 2019
عوامل اخرى اسهمت في زياده الهجمات بنسبه
52% منذ الحادي عشر من ابريل الماضي وهي
تولي وهي تولي عفوا احسب شهباز شريف
الحكومه الباكستانيه لا خلافاتنا شريف مع
واشنطن خلافا لسلفه عمران خان سيناريو
اشرف غني في افغانستان قد يتكرر بالعوده
الى الهجمات كان اكثرها في مناطق البشتون
ولايه خيبر بخته نخوه المنطقه الحدوديه
المحاديه لافغانستان من الشمال الغربي
اخرها حادثه احتجاز على يده ثلاثه وثلاثين
سجينا من عناصر طالبان باكستان في مركز
الشرطه في خيبر بخته نخوه المطالب كانت
لافغانستان ولكن
دوله كانت لها كلمتها قتلت الخاطفين
وحررت الرهائن اهدافه الحركه الباكستانيه
كما نظيرتها تريد ذات الغنائم الاطاحه
بحكومه بلادها وفرض قوانينها الصارمه من
بينها حضر التعليم للفتيات كما فعل طالبا
في افغانستان قبل ايام وسنعود الى هذه
النقطه لاحقا على اسلام اباد ان تقلق قد
لا يكون الامر سهلا عليها كما يعتقد
قادتها
تشجع طالبا باكستان لتكرار ما حدث على
الاقل في مناطق البشتون مخاوف السفير
الباكستاني الاسبق لدى واشنطن احسن حقاني
في الخامس عشر من اغسطس عام 2021 عندما
سقطت العاصمه الافنيه كابول 15 شهرا كانت
كفيله وكافيه لاظهار صحه رؤيته رغم ترحيب
المسؤولين الباكستانيه الباكستانيين وقتها
بسيبان
استخدمت الاراضي الافغانيه لضرب اهداف في
باكستان ومنها اماكن على الحدود هل هذا
سبب تصاعد التوتر اذا
باكستان متهمه بنظري طالبا الافغانيه سمحت
للمسيرات الامريكيه في استخدام مجالها
الجوي لاختراق الاجواء الافغانيه والاتهام
جاء تحديدا بعد عمليه اغتيال زعيم تنظيم
القاعده ايمن الظواهري في اغسطس الماضي
ولتتصاعد بعدها حده الهجمات هجمات طالبان
باكستان على الحدود وهنا يتوجب على
الحكومه الباكستانيه الرد على هذا التصعيد
هناك تاثيرا للاوضاع في افغانستان هي
طالوا باكستان وزير الدفاع الباكستانيه
التي ذكرناها قبل قليل باكستان امام ضروره
مواجهه طالبه الهدنه الهشاشه الحركه هي
العقبه الكبرى امام التعاون الامني بين
كابل اسلام اباد وعلي اقرت باكستان في
نهايه العام الماضي اولا قانونا للامن
الوطني لمواجهه طالبان وكانت نتيجته منذ
ذلك الوقت عمليه عسكريه ضد طالبان باكستان
داخل الاراضي الافغانيه وعلى الحدود ومن
اجل هذه المواجهه عين قائد جديد للجيش قبل
شهر الجنرال عاصم منير يعتبره
الباكستانيون الامل في مواجهه الحركه بسبب
خبراته لاستخبراته العسكريه وفهمه لطبيعه
طالبا باكستان لكن اسلام اباد لن تكون
وحيده في هذه المواجهه واشنطن في الصوره
وضعت واشنطن قائد دفاعي حركه طالبان
باكستان اقاري امجد اعلى قوائم الارهاب
رساله وتهديدا مباشره اخرى من الولايات
المتحده جاءت اليسا في ريباكستان في
الولايات المتحده والعهده على زعيم حركه
طالبا باكستان نور والي محسود وهذا يعني
ان المشاركه الامريكيه في ضربات على
الحركه وقادتها امر وارد سيناري الظواهري
ليس
ببعيدها على البلاد الحصول على الاعتراف
الدولي لكن
وعودها جعل دولا عده ترفض اطفاء الشرعيه
السياسه الخارجيه بالطبع سبب لكن سياستها
الداخليه
جعلت من الامر مستحيلا
[موسيقى]
بكت فتيات المدارس في مارس الماضي اثرى
حضري تعليمهن تكرر المشهد بعد تسعه اشهر
طالبات الجامعه طالبان ساوت بينهم لامراه
ستتعلم لا في المدارس ولا في الجامعه
طالبان تعهدت بان لا يتاثر تعليم الفتيات
بعد تسلمها السلطه وتبرر الان خطواتها لما
تراعي الفتيات الحجاب ولا عدم الاختلاط
بالشباب وبعض المناهج مهينه لكرامه المراه
خاصه الهندسه والزراعه هنا وزير التعليم
العالي في طالبان ندى محمد نديم يتحدث وال
المفارقه هذا الطالبان يرسلون بناتهن
للتعلم في الخارج فيما تلتحق بعضا من هنا
الى المدارس
في الداخل بحسب صحيفه
وهذا ما ينقلنا للنقطه التاليه الحركه
منقمه في داخلها بسبب هذه القرارات القرار
جاء مباشره
منه هبه الله اخونزه ده بمباركه من رئيس
القضاء ووزير الشؤون الدينيه وهناك من
عارض في العالم كنائب وزير الخارجيه الشيخ
محمد عباس الثاني زايد رجل الدين في
طالبان ايضا رحيم الله حقاني قبل مقتله
على يد داعش لاحقا هو الاخر شدد ان كل
الكتب الدينيه نصت على ان التعليم الاناث
الزاميه اعتراضات داخليه وصل صداها للشعب
ايضا والاحتجاجات لم تكن نسائيه بحتها
كمان نشاهد هناك الشباب تضامنوا مع
زميلاتهم
وانسحبوا من امتحاناتهم
ووسطى هذه التظاهرات والتمديد الدولي
للقرارات هناك معترض جديد وهنا مفارق اخرى
ايران
تعليم الفتيات في افغانستان
حين تخدمنا التكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي
من اجل زراعه افضل وغذاء اكثر في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
الذي تعمل فيه وهذا تعهد للرئيس التنفيذي
للشركه تم كوك الان بات مطالب بالتنفيذ
تحديدا في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي معركه
الون ماسك مع افل انتقلت من امريكا الى
اوروبا ومن نفس الفكره الرغبه في الغاء
الاحتكار وهنا ياتي القانون الاوروبي
الجديد للاسواق الرقميه وبالمناسبه واشنطن
ايضا تقترح تشريعا مشابها يناقش في
الكونغرس حاليا
في اوروبا تحديدا من 29 مليارا من اصل
خمسه و90 حققتها في هذا العام في دول
الاتحاد اتت من المتجر 30% هي عموله افل
على المشتريات من ابل ستور سياسا فقدها
الكثيرون مالك ايفون لا يمكنك تنزيل اي
تطبيق الا من خلال هذا المتجر لكن وفق
القانون الجديد على ابل الان السماح
بالتنزيلات المباشره من متاجر بديله او
التحميل الجانبي للتطبيقات من الويب كما
يحدث في اجهزه اندرويد لا خيار بديل الان
امام الشركه الرفض يعني غرامه اوروبيه تصل
الى 20% من ايرادتها السنويه نتحدث تقريبا
عن 80 مليار من اصل 400 مليار حققتها هذا
العام اما اقفل الوقت
الامتثال لجميع بنود القانون سيكون بدءا
من 2024 و رغم انه سيدخل حيز التنفيذ في
مايو 2023 لكن ابل لا تلعب ورقه الوقت
تلعب ورقه اخرى تجاوز متجر ابل ستور ويعرض
المستخدمين يعرض المستخدمين لمخاطر الامن
والخصوصيه وهذه كلمات المطورين في ابل
تبدو ورقه مهمه لا يريد اي مستخدم طبعا
فقدان هذه الميزه ولو كلفه اموالا اضافيه
المنافسه صعب ايضا ولهذا السبب تتوقع
مؤسسات سي اف ار اي للابحار تاثر اقل من
صفر فاصله اثنين في المئه فقط من اجماليات
مبيعات ابل مشكله اخرى فرضها القانون
الجديد على قفا رسميا باتا امام الشركه 24
24 شهرا ليتم استخدام شاحن من نوع سي
معي هواتفها مثل المستخدمه في جميع
الاجهزه الذكيه هل ابل واحده معنيه بهذا
القرار بالطبع له جميع شركات التكنولوجيا
التي تبيع منتجاتها في اوروبا مولزمه
لتصنيع اجهزه محموله ملائمه لشواحن من هذا
النوع اذا لماذا نركز على ابل لان ابل تحت
كان اكبر حصه سوقيه من بيعهاواتفها داخل
اوروبا وبالنسبه تصل الى 35% فكره الشاحن
المشترك لجميع الاجهزه جاءت وفقا لحل ثلاث
قضايا اساسيه واولها جعل المنتجات اكثر
استدامه وتقليل النفايات الالكترونيه
وتسهيل حياه المستهلكين في اوروبا نهجنا
انه يتعارض مع الاهداف الثلاثه لا يعقل ان
يضطر اكثر من مليار مستخدم الى التخلص من
شواحن اللايتنج الحاليه والشراء موصل لربط
الشاحن وقد يختلف الطرفان لكن الكل متفق
على ضروره تخفيض بصمته الكربونيه من
النفايات الالكترونيه تخيلوا ان البشر في
عام 2001 فقط تخلصوا من النفايات
الكترونيه يفوقوا حجمها حجم صوره الصين
العظيم نعم نتحدث عن ثلاثه و60 مليون ثم
تقريبا من النفايات المرصوصه على مسافه
21,000 كلم هناك همم سور اخر من هذه
النفايات موجود في اوروبا ويمتد من اوسلوه
الى طرف ايطاليا على مسافه 3500 كم تقريبا
وبارتفاع 10 امتار هذا يمثل اربعه ملايين
و700,000 طن من النفايات الالكترونيه
والنسبه تزيد اثنين في المئه في العام اذا
اخذنا الشواحن وحدها فهي تمثل ما بين احد
عشر الى 13
طن مثل النفايات وتخرج انبعاثات تخرج
انبعاثات عفوا بحجم 600 الى 900.000 طنن
من مكافئ ثاني اكسيد الكربون نتخيل كيف
سيكون تاثير الانبعاثات انبعاثات الشواحن
فقط على البيئه من الهواء الذي نتنفسه الى
الغذاء الذي ناكله ومن اللحام والعالم مع
العلم ان الطن الواحد فقط من انبعاثات
ثاني اكسيد الكربون يعادل قياده سيارات
تعمل بالديزل لمسافه سته الاف كيلومتر
عمليا تكمل مشكله
الانبعاثات ابي طريقه تصريفها والتخلص
منها والحل يبدا من هنا
[موسيقى]
ثمانيه 38 من اجمل مساحه اليابسه في
العالم
هي الوسيله في ذلك
مزايا كثيره توفرها الروبوتات الاليه في
الزراعه تعملوا 24 ساعه في اليوم ما يعني
فرصه للحصاد في كل الاوقات صباح الباكر
تحديدا وهو افضل وقت للثمار من حيث النضج
ومحتوى الماء
الروبوتات تساهم ايضا في قطف المحاصيل فقط
عندما تكون جاهزه ما يقلل من الفاقد ويحسن
من الجوده
اخرى وهي جمع البيانات عبر اجهزه
الاستشعار
بالتوازي مع الحصاد وهنا يعرف المزارعون
الكميات ومدى جودتها
الروبوت يتم تصميمه بحيث يمكنه التحكم
لقوه عمليه الحصاد وفقا لنوع الثمر
المزروعه بحيث لا تتلفها
القبض ان يحتوي ايضا على كاميرا توفر
معلومات حول مسافه الروبوت من الفاكهه
ويمكن لروبوتات ايضا لازاله الاعشاب
الضاره في غضون يوم الى اثنين وهي مهمه
تستغرق اسابيع اذا اجريت يدويا هذا طبعا
عن عامل السرعه ما يعني زياده الامدادات
الاجماليه من الغذاء المشكله الوحيده حتى
الان هو ان الروبوتات فقط تلغي بعض
الوظائف لكنها قد لا تكون مشكله كبيره ان
علمنا ان نسبه اصابه ومرض العمال
المزارعين
مرتفع للغايه بسبب طول ساعات العمل في
ظروفيه مختلفه
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى نهايه الساعه
وتتابعونا غدا في الساعه الستون قراني
يحاول بلء فراغ السليماني باستغلال خروج
الكاظمي من منصبه زال الحاجز فظهرت
التسهيلات المحيط الهادئ ليس هادئا تغيرا
تاريخي الي ثوابت استمرت نصف قرن اليابان
تستشعر الخطر الصيني
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الساعه ابرز واحداث الساعه بصور
من الان 1/9 المقبله انا حنين الشولي وهذه
الساعه
[موسيقى]